this will be real quick I wasn't
intending to do it but I've got a
question about it and I can't not show
you because it's such a charming theme
so just um eyes up for a minute I
promise we'll be very brief in January
grab a seat would help so remember we
said this the unit circle gives you a
new definition for sine and cos that's
sort of nothing to do with triangles
anymore it's to do with this circle and
where you are on it that's very
important because when you have angles
bigger than 180 degrees you can't fit
them in triangles right it's like that
thing you can't draw any triangle that
can contain those angles so that's why
the unit circle helps us there but the
astute among you will have noticed it
only redefines sine and cos and we're
missing 10 now the first thing is you
can say well you can just work out ten
from those guys right because our
definition for ten if you recall was the
ratio of sine over cos right and in fact
that explains why because this is
opposite on hypotenuse and this is
adjacent on hypotenuse you've got a
fraction a fraction and a fraction the
hypotenuse is hypotenuse
they cancel right so that's why you get
just opposite on adjacent the hypotenuse
is argon right but and this is the thing
I love so much it doesn't explain
anything about why tan is called tan
does anyone not tan is an abbreviation
of
tangent which is two like I know what
that is but what does that have to do
with anything
triangles don't have tangents
but circles do so have a look here's
where I put theta before right we know
cos theta is the x coordinate of that
point sine theta is the y coordinate of
that point but what would be the tangent
think goes with this angle will let me
draw it in for you okay what's tricky
about it is because tangents are outside
circles I need to extend this line a
little further I'm going to draw a
tangent up from this point here what's
that one comma zero okay and I'm going
to draw it up it's tangent like so until
it meets that was a squeaky sound until
it meets that radius if I extended it
okay yeah think about this with me all
right if this is a right angle because
actually you guys don't learn anymore
that the tangent is perpendicular to the
radius but it is
that's a right angle what's this length
along here it's the unit circle right
that's one deal great yeah now just have
a look here think about this we worked
out I'll put the triangle back so you
can see it we worked out this length and
this length by saying oh this is the
adjacent side this is the opposite side
right I want you to try and work out
what would that side be in terms of this
triangle what ratio it leaks this side
to this side gets its opposite on
adjacent that's that's ten right so tan
theta equals opposite on adjacent so
this this side here is tan theta this is
the mean why is it called tan it's the
length of that part of the tangent
formed by this angle if you gave me a
bigger angle right then the this would
extend a higher and you would go further
along and your tangent would be longer
so your tan of this length is higher so
for instance if we said why don't we say
a tan of PI on 4 that's 10 to 45 degrees
this is a number you should know what is
it what's the exact value 10 to 45
degrees think think think this is a
number this is a ratio between just it's
1/10 of pi and 4 that should make sense
because PI on 4 look at that see if
that's piled 4 this is 1 this is 1
it's just squared do you see that that's
the length 1 would be the length of that
tangent if I increase the size of the
angle to something like let's go
trying to think of a nice angle that you
guys let's just do two no that's not
right let's just do pound three it'll
illustrate now 10 PI on 3 you can pop
this in your calculator if it's in
radians mode what do you get 10 of pound
3
one point one point seven dot dot dot
that's root three I'm pretty sure you
can chuck in root three and see if it's
the same number that should makes it
it's longer because pylon 3 is a higher
angle so you're getting a longer tangent
right what would happen if you had an
angle of play on to what would happen
when would this line meet that tangent
where would this line mate that tangent
the answer is never
which is why if you try ten of Pi on to
your calculator says forget it I can't
do that come back out I never connected
that tangent it's undefined
okay so pause is the x-coordinate on the
circle why is the sorry sine is the
y-coordinate ten is the length of this
tangent that you get when you extend
upwards okay you don't need to know that
but for me I'm kind of like it's kind of
frustrating that I've I studied I did a
whole mathematics degree using this
thing never knowing why I was called
what I was called and that's the reason